[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 le
tour des informations locales en 26
minutes voici les titres de ce mercredi
12 février une action à quelques jours
de la saint-valentin le collectif nous
tout a distribué des violentes au maître
aux yvelinois l'objectif mesurer les
violences au sein du couple
trois mille questionnaires ont été
donnés dans six communes du département
c'est le cinéma de trappes le grenier à
sel fait en 2020 ses 100 ans d'existence
le bâtiment qui accueille la salle de
projection est le plus vieux de la ville
un cinéma art et essai qui a su
s'adapter à son temps et aux différentes
innovations
enfin les élections municipales parmi
les quatre candidats en lice à plaisir
djamel niati le conseiller municipal
d'opposition conduit la liste à gauche
tout soutenu notamment par génération le
parti communiste et la france insoumise
présentation à suivre également dans ce
journal du prix de la toile de jouy qui
vient d'être lancé tout récemment et je
vous en parlais dans les titres cette
démarche de l'antenne yvelinoise de nous
tout
al'approche de la saint valentin ils ont
distribué à la distribuer des violentes
au m il ya quelques jours un outil pour
mesurer les violences conjugales
marylène iapichino a suivi l'action à
versailles bonjour madame adresse à cet
égard solaire c'est sur les violences
faites aux femmes
ce questionnaire c'est un violent tôt m
un outil de mesure des violences
psychologiques et physiques au sein du
couple
cet outil permet de se situer de voir si
on est dans la zone verte ce qui est
très bien d'où vient la zone orange ou
là il faut commencer à réagir et la zone
rouge où là il faut vraiment pas retirer
et se faire aider
ça peut être un outil qui qui amorce de
dialogue
al'approche de la saint valentin le
collectif nous tout soixante dix huit
s'est dit que cette fête des coupes
seraient meilleurs sans violence ils
sont 30 à distribuer 3000 violente au
maître tout le week-end dans six
communes des yvelines
notre but est plutôt d'attirer
l'attention et des veillées et puis
aussi des permettent à certaines
personnes qui n'osent pas aborder les
sujets peut-être d'ouvrir la discussion
ou de les aider à prendre conscience des
climats des violences qu'elles peuvent
vivre
je pense que c'est un outil pour une
prise de conscience oui ça serait bien
mais je trouve que c'est bien ça quand
même ça permet quand même aux gens de
dévaluer en fait parce qu'on peut
toujours se dire voilà c'est non il va
il va changer c'est lorsqu'on se dit et
puis en fait ben non il s'enflammait et
effectivement ça permet de mettre des
mots sur des actions et sur des
ressentis
le collectif nous tout des yvelines
envisage déjà de recommencer
l'expérience pour poursuivre la
sensibilisation prochaines distributions
prévues devant l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à destination
des étudiants depuis le 1er janvier 2020
des femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint dont une dans
les yvelines
selon le collectif dans l'actualité
également 40 véhicules électriques
renault zoé ont été livrés au conseil
départemental à versailles en provenance
de l'usiné de flins sur seine
en tout ce sont 185 voitures qui seront
mises à disposition un investissement de
4 millions et demi d'euros pour
renouveler la flotte de la collectivité
participe également la transition
écologique du département une nouvelle
commande de 200 autres véhicules est
prévue pour l'année 2000 21è les propos
recueillis par mathilde et demi et
jacques brun je crois profondément
ont nécessité la transition énergétique
je crois profondément à la nécessité
qu'il y a que chaque collectivité à son
échelle essaye d'être un bon élève et
que ce sont des petites gouttes de sang
voiture c'est vrai qu'à l'échelle des
yvelines où il ya plusieurs centaines de
milliers de voitures qui sont la
propriété des habitants ça paraît être
une toute petite goutte mais je pense
que c'est un premier exemple c'est un
calcul je pense réfléchi faut pas
oublier que la consommation de carburant
donc du coup sera à zéro pendant part
nous montrent pas mal d'années je pense
qu'ils vont garder les véhicules assez
longtemps donc le retour sur
investissement se rassurera net et clair
[Musique]
il souffle cette année ses 100 bougies
le grenier à sel de trappes a atteint un
siècle d'existence son temps comme
cinéma pour ce bâtiment déjà présent à
l'époque médiévale dans la ville salles
art et essai a franchi l les années sans
cessé de se renouveler le reportage sur
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
il s'est appelé au cours de son
existence la grange de doueir puis le
normandie avant de devenir le grenier à
sel à la fin des années 1970
l'activité cinématographique de ce lieu
emblématique de trappes et démarre après
la première guerre mondiale mais son
histoire remonte à bien plus loin
les prémices de ce bâtiment le plus
vieux de la ville sont visibles à la fin
du moyen-âge le grenier est alors un
dépôt de celles collectées par un impôt
la gabelle à la gabelle donc à la à
l'impôt sur le sel est là la grandeur de
cette bâtisse nous laissant entendre que
c'était un lieu de stockage mais aussi
un lieu de vente
le site devient ensuite au xvième siècle
une poste aux chevaux un service de
relais pour le transport des voyageurs
et leurs bagages
l'histoire du grenier à sel est en fait
alliée à celle de l'étoile d'or
l'auberge attenante
en 1919 le propriétaire du lieu demande
à la mairie l'autorisation de créer une
activité cinéma fixe à une époque où les
projections sont plutôt itinérante
les premières séances ont lieu dès 1920
la grosse activité cinéma démarre
officiellement avec
en 1945 à la sortie de la guerre où le
cinéma ou la grange devient le normandie
le cinéma le normandie et le normandie
s'arrête
en 1975 puis 6 puis le bâtiment est
repris par la ville
restauration en 1979 qui laisse
apparaître les pierres meulières du
bâtiment encore visibles aujourd'hui un
lieu avant tout d'innovation
technologique le cinéma inaugure en 1964
un écran révolutionnaire le deuxième du
type installé dans le monde l'heracles
orama c'était un écran courbes avec des
lamelles en métal qui permettait d'avoir
avec un certain objectif qui permettait
d'avoir une impression de profondeur
donc on pouvait projeter n'importe quel
film du commerce et avoir une impression
de profondeur s'était pas le relief
encore mais c'était déjà une grande
avancée technologique en 2012 le grenier
à sel s'équipe d'un projecteur 4k l'une
des premières salles à se convertir à
l'ultra haute définition elle malgré son
grand âge le cinéma de trappes n'a cessé
de se renouveler un oeil toujours tourné
vers l'avenir et bon anniversaire au
grenier à sel on reste d'ailleurs sur
place pour connaître la programmation
des films à l'affiché cette semaine
comme chaque mercredi c'est notre rendez
vous habituel dans les salles du cinéma
du territoire et c'est au micro une
nouvelle fois de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
vous avez vu les résultats des oscars
parasite le film sud-coréen qui a
remporté le film nominé aux oscars et 4
4 oscars en tout c'est incroyable c'est
super parce que ce film là non l'adorent
donc à parasite en version noir et blanc
au cinéma le grenier à sel c'est bientôt
nous avons aussi
un événement japonais a dont vous voulez
vous parler c'est un fils ya un film qui
s'appelle dans un jardin qu'on croyait
qu'on dirait éternelle c'est l'histoire
de deux jeunes filles qui vont découvrir
là
à la cérémonie traditionnelle du thé
c'est l'occasion pour nous de faire
dormir avec des dégustations dégustation
de thé évidemment puisque c'est le sujet
du film mais aussi ce sera donc il y
aura un thé gratuit et il y aura aussi
des pâtisseries et des mini benneteau à
acheter donc ce sera ça à la toute fin
des vacances ce dimanche 23 février à
17h15
nous avons un autre événement dont on
vous voulez vous parler au mois de mars
il ya la journée du des droits des
femmes et nous le samedi 7 mars à 15
heures où nous diffuserons le film oman
qui est coréalisé par la nature arthus
bertrand
j'en profite pour vous dire que vous
pouvez réserver vos places directement
sur notre site nous avons une billeterie
en ligne
et nous avons une innovation aussi un
système s'appelle toi box qui permet aux
malentendants mal voyants sourds non
voyants de venir profiter du cinéma
comme comme tout comme nous tous si vous
voulez en savoir plus vous regardez sur
notre site où vous demander à l'accueil
au cinéma trois représentations qui
était proposé en fin de semaine dernière
au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les ballets de
monte-carlo revisitait cendrillon au
rire on a pu assister à la répétition
générale de la compagnie monégasque
[Musique]
il était une fois un gentilhomme qui
épousa en secondes noces une femme la
plus hot n est la plus fière qu'on lui
jamais vu ainsi commence l'histoire de
cendrillon de charles perrault
un conte réadapter depuis 20 ans par la
célèbre compagnie des ballets de monte
carlo
un ballet néoclassique chorégraphié par
jean christophe maillot et la base de
son travail toujours du classique c'est
sûr pointe pour lui mais c'est beaucoup
c'est très moderne c'est quelque chose
qui est très différent de ce qu'on
connaît habituellement et c'est ça qui
qui fait la force des ballets
saint-christophe c'est la cinquième fois
que la compagnie monégasque vient
présenter ses balais sur la scène du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
durant deux heures une cinquantaine de
danseuses et danseurs font revivre la
célèbre histoire sur une musique de
prokofiev
sur scène tout senti vibrer rêve un
conte de fées qui propose également une
réflexion sur le souvenir des personnes
disparues
il a toujours cependant chez jean
christophe maillot de d'avoir deux
personnages comme ça qui raconte une
histoire est effectivement la maman de
cendrillon qu'on connaît tous dans
l'histoire qui est décédé dès le début
du spectacle
et à chaque fois il ya une référence et
là on verra quand même la maman il la
ramène à d'autres à d'autres choses dans
le spectacle qui sont assez inattendu
autre différence avec le conte original
il n'y a pas de pantoufle de verre dans
cette version à la place les pieds nus
de cendrillon sont trempés dans un banc
de paillettes
un détail vo lu par le chorégraphe
pour lui le pied de la danseuse
évidemment c'est quelque chose de
fondamental sur la silhouette est sûre
le l'histoire même d'une danseuse et le
fait de la plongée dans une bande
l'étang des paillettes et de magnifier
la le pied c'est c'est cendrillon fait
le cloud eu l'idée de vue du ballet un
pied sans tillon qui saura séduire le
prince et le public
un ballet où l'émotion mais aussi les
sourires sont au rendez vous et qui se
termine par cette phrase bien connue
ils vécurent heureux allez un dernier
mot de culture avec le prix de la toile
de jouy dont la première édition vient
de démarrer
regardez cette interview enregistrée en
début de semaine avec l'un des
organisateurs avec moi en plateau et
yann malet bonsoir choix président des
amis du musée de la toile de jouy à jouy
en josas la commune lieu de création au
xviiie siècle de ce célèbre tissu créé
par oberkampf qui jouit encore c'est le
cas de le dire d'une belle réputation
aujourd'hui les créateurs sont inspire
l'association avec le musée de la toile
de jouy ont lancé en janvier un prix un
prix de la toile de jouy c'est jusqu'au
16 mai le dépôt des candidatures est
fixé jusqu'au 15 mars
déjà pourquoi lancer ce prix quels sont
les objectifs bah écoutez d'abord il ya
un engouement pour la toile de jouer
vous venez de le dire pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans notre région mais au
niveau international c'est connu dans le
monde entier et on s'aperçoit que le
plus en plus de gens nous interroge
viennent au musée ce que je recommande
vivement à tous les téléspectateurs de
faire parce qu'il ya des expositions
permanentes temporaires etc et donc face
à cette demande très forte poussée d'ibm
au fond pourquoi pas créer appris la
toile de jouy qu'ils fassent un pont
entre l'ancien je dirais et le moderne
et le contemporain
c'est ça l'idée d'ailleurs qu'elle a
besoin sans cesse de
réinventer en tout cas d'avoir de
nouveaux talents qui gaspille comme
comme la toile de jouy et une est
extrêmement riche en thèmes variés il ya
plus de 30000 motifs différents qui sont
sortis de la manufacture c'est à jouy en
josas au xviiie siècle jusqu'au xixème
siècle d'ailleurs et donc les thèmes
sont extrêmement variés et continue
d'inspirer des décors acteurs
d'aujourd'hui est donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas lancer un concours sur le
thème de la nature retrouve figure est
revisitée mais avec une vision actuelle
de ses motifs
c'était ça l'idée est donc s'intéresser
donc à des jeunes créateurs étudiants
mais aussi à des professionnels qui son
métier si vous voulez de faire de la
décoration de l'ameublement ou de la
mode une grande variété vous dites la
toile de jouer et est reconnue dès sa
création xviiie siècle aussi pour sa
qualité
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle était
prisé par la bourgeoisie par la cour
royale aussi à l'époque absolument
d'ailleurs c'était commode puisque jouy
en josas est tout près de versailles a
fait et donc il y avait à la fois l'eau
puisque c'était la vallée de la bièvre
et la bièvre et puis il y avait le les
clients et c'était la cour de versailles
effectivement qui était très affriolante
est très intéressé par tout ce qui
tournait autour de la toile de jouy pour
pour s'habiller et pour décorer leur
intérieur nancy on vient au prix qui est
lancé vous l'avez dit les candidats
devront proposer une nature imaginaire
c'est ça le principe oui et devront
faire preuve d'imagination pour pas
forcément faire une nature imaginaire ça
peut être une nature très réaliste c'est
à eux de voir
mais si vous voulez de s'inspirer le
motif qu'ils sont anciens mais dont
certains d'ailleurs ont une même si on
les regarde de près on écoute et très
moderne il ya desquels fois les motifs
géométriques par exemple qui ressemblent
à des tableaux tout à fait contemporain
et donc pour ce prix et en fait même
deux prix de catégorie expliquez-nous la
différence alors parce que si vous
voulez ya d'une part des jeunes
étudiants l'élève
1 qui sont donc en cours de scolarité et
qu'ils veulent on les comprend père
s'est petit à petit et c'est donc qu'ils
peuvent à l'occasion de ce prix puisque
l'étoile et leurs oeuvres seront
exposées non seulement d'ôter la prime
est exposé et donc connu ça peut être
pour eux une petite rampe de lancement
pour leur carrière puis d'autre part il
ya la seconde catégorie qui sont
s'adresse plutôt à des professionnels
plus confirmés et celle là bas c'est
simplement pour cul parce que c'est un
métier si vous voulez qui a besoin
d'être connu reconnu et le prix peut
être notoriété pour leur travail comme
on y participe à feu on s'inscrit tout
simplement on s'inscrit sur le site du
musée la toile de jouer qui est en train
de s'afficher et on suit on suit le mode
d'emploi
alors la date limite et fx et je le
disais des candidatures en au 15 mars
toutes les infos vous l'avais dit à
retrouver sur le site du musée de la
toile de jouy un mot pour terminer sur
votre association les amis du musée de
la toile de jouy
quel est son rôle est finalement quel
complément avec ce musée qui est située
à jouy en josas
et bien si vous voulez son rôle c'est
d'accompagner le développement de ce
musée donc d'organiser si vous voulez
tout ce qui peut faciliter sa notoriété
son développement ses finances fait
appel au mécénat ont fait appel à nos
adhérents et on fait appel on fait des
conférences on organise des visites dans
des lieux différents qui ont un peu des
rapports évidemment avec la toile de
jouy
mais dans les musées parisiens ou dans
des musées en province ou château de
versailles
et tout ça en faveur si vous voulez de
l'association et du musée de manière à
ce qu'ils aient des retombées de
notoriété mais aussi des retombées
financières puisque amusé c'est toujours
lieu qui a besoin de finances et donc on
s'emploie à ce qu'ils ont elles au
maximum finalement ce prix ça participe
aux actions de l'association faire la
promotion de la toile de lin absolument
merci etienne mallet d'être venu en
parler en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association des
amis du musée
de la toile de jouy donc à jouy en josas
toutes les informations sur cette
association a retrouvé sur son site
internet elle la partie de ce journal
dédié aux élections municipales et c'est
à la ville de plaisir que nous nous
intéressons ce soir quatre listes sont
pour le moment
candidate au scrutin soutenu par europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste l'élu d'opposition annie joël
priou hasseni est à la tête de taf le
nom de cette liste tout à faire pour
plaisir reportage de marie la nahia
piccino lors d'une déambulation
allez on y va c'est parti une
déambulation au départ du quartier des
épis noirs pour l'état ferait les
militants de la liste écologique et
solidaire tout à faire pour plaisir dit
taf sont allés à la rencontre des
habitants armés de branches de bambou
pour présenter leurs tracts
nous on est sur le terrain à chaque fois
on rencontre les plaisirs oies et on
voit que lille enfin eux nous disent
qu'il y à des dysfonctionnements on
écoute ce qu'ils nous disent et non
seulement on écoute mais on s'est aussi
engagé à travailler là dessus et à faire
des propositions des propositions
également réfléchi lors d'ateliers avec
les plaisirs watts depuis fin novembre
orienté sur les solidarités en recréant
du lien entre les quartiers aisés entre
les générations et sur l'écologie
plaisir malheureusement est voué aux
voitures
aucune autre façon de voir une autre
façon de recréer sur le terrain des
choses des éléments qui permettent de
satisfaire les plaisirs candidate sans
étiquette la liste citoyenne est tout de
même soutenu par europe ecologie les
verts et le parti socialiste revendique
ses valeurs écologistes et de gauche
je constate tous les jours le
l'augmentation des constructions
la non prise en charge de certaines
populations et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage donc je fais entièrement
confiance à cette liste et on saisit des
pour pouvoir essayer d'améliorer les
choses tout à faire pour plaisir a
poursuivi sa déambulation jusqu'à la
gare plaisir avec les trois autres
listes sont déclarés pour les élections
municipales dans la commune à bientôt
une autre liste candidate justement à
plaisir mené par un conseiller municipal
d'opposition également séduit à magna
t-bonds soir bonsoir
vous êtes la tête de liste d' à gauche
tout donc c'est une liste qui est
soutenu notamment par la france
insoumise le parti communiste génération
et le parti de gauche
aucune alliance d'ailleurs n'a été
envisagée avec cette candidature dont on
vient de vendre leurs reportages qui est
soutenue elle par le parti socialiste
europe écologie les verts ont pour ce
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans la continuité de notre
engagement de 2014 et voire même avant
donc notre démarche c'est nous est
propre aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
véritablement de deux logiques rapport à
ça non vous étiez déjà candidat vous le
dites en 2014
vous aviez récolté 7 45% des suffrages
alors d'une élection municipale en un
tour puisque joséphine coleman ce berger
avait été élu dès ce premier tour vous
êtes aujourd'hui membre de l'opposition
pourquoi aller justement de nouveau dans
cette bataille des municipales
déjà parce qu'on a créé une dynamique en
son temps
dans une démarche où nous avions en face
de nous battre gauche ou droite pardon
très dur mais on l'a constaté lors dé
cette mandature
et puis pourquoi continuer tout
simplement ce qui est une dynamique et
on a envie véritablement de remettre les
plaisirs roi au centre de la vie plaisir
parce que tout simplement il a mené dans
une logique où donc ça y est on a une
approche qui est très simple on a un
socle qui se base sur une démarche est
une méthode déjà la méthode de c'est
tout simplement une approche qui est
voué à laisser parler les plaisirs oies
à s'exprimer c'est la démocratie partie
de l'année j'allais dire des manguiers
de participer participative
oui par par nature mais par une
différente différents moyens vient
évidemment mais sur le principe c'est la
méthode c'est véritablement de laisser
les gens s'exprimer là aujourd'hui on
est dans une logique politique et tous
bords confondus aujourd'hui / / / /
plaisir on parle et vous parliez des des
candidats j'ai parlé de tout ce qui ne
concerne aujourd'hui nous on est dans
une démarche où les plaisirs wam n'ont
pas foi aujourd'hui au chapitre on
impose des choses on fait des choses
sans que son que ce soit vous savez
plaisir c'est un centre commercial à
celle ouvert aujourd'hui tout simplement
dont je veux dire qu'il ya rien pour les
jeunes mais rien pour les tout jeunes
et puis encore un pour les seniors donc
pourquoi continuer tout simplement pour
faire changer les choses c'est dans
l'action que l'on peut que que l'on
s'inscrit on souhaite véritablement
changer les choses mais retravailler la
gauche peut revenir à la tête de plaisir
la ville avait déjà été à gauche il ya
plusieurs années et c'est une ville qui
à droite le précise depuis 2001 tout à
fait tout à fait et je ne referai pas
l'histoire mais par nature vous avez
vous le savez vous allez travailler sur
nos fiches imagine sur le principe la
ville était à gauche en 2001 et même au
premier tour en dominant c'est d'édition
des problèmes d'ego qui ont fait que la
ville est passé à droite et avec une
droite dure c'est ce que je vous disais
sur le principe on est dans une droite
qui a cassé tous les services publics
qui est cassé toute cette proximité et
qui aujourd'hui fait durant devant
partir d'une approche artificielle et
superficiel donc oui voilà c'est c'est
tout tout ce qui est le lien social de
cette ville est partie quoi et donc nous
dans notre démarche c'est véritablement
remettre de l'humain au centre de tout
ça aujourd'hui on discute avec des gens
ce sont des comptables quel qu'il soit
aujourd'hui donc nous la démarche faire
de la politique c'est servir les gens
c'est pas se servir des gens juste avant
de parler du reste de votre démarche on
a parlé de la démocratie locale
autre regard sur le travail qui a été
menée par la précédente majorité celle
qui est allé donc de 2014 à 2020 et qui
a été menée par la maire sortante
joséphine coleman verdoyant l'emporter
si j'osais si j'osais je vous dirais
regarder ce qu'en dit son plus fidèle
lieutenant qui un regard qui est
beaucoup plus acérées que le nôtre nous
on avait exalté se voit là pour ne pas
le nommer
sur le principe nous on a eu du mal à
nous on a été lucide depuis début on a
dénoncé l' approche déjà autocratique et
l'autoritarisme de madame comme anne
berger
il s'avère que ben a perdu pas mal de
ces policiers feront un tiers si je ne
m'abuse
donc voilà on a eu tort d'avoir raison
avant tout le monde sur le principe ya
aucune concertation c'est de la
communication mais de deux étages c'est
c'est durant pauline âge comme on dit
nous sur le principe la démarche allait
très simple c'est de remettre plaisir au
centre de la ville et plaisir
aujourd'hui plaisir c'est une cité
dortoir une fois au faut pas se voiler
la face il ya rien n'est fait rien n'est
mis en oeuvre
et pourquoi pas ce qu'on me consignes a
pas de concertation sur plaisir il n'y a
aucune concertation
c'est à dire on vient saluer le plus dur
dans cette dans cette ville c'est bas de
se faire élire je vais dire
effectivement c'est compliqué d'après
revenez au bout de six ans et puis vous
vous ne fait même pas de bilan vous ne
faites rien du tout donc la démarche
allait quand même aujourd'hui de
remettre véritablement où il l on va
dire sur eux sur des ouvrages mais de
manière régulière c'est à dire on doit
on doit des comptes aux gens on doit des
comptes aux gens c'est pas un
blanc-seing de les autres socles de
votre démarche il ya une idée qui
prévaut aussi c'est l'écologie est une
idée traditionnellement de gauche mais
qu'on voit apparaître dans les
programmes des différents candidats sur
surface élections municipales l'écologie
c'est une grosse association les
propositions d'écologie j'ai envie de
dire l'écologie aujourd'hui quand
j'entends que des propositions à tout va
l'écologie au centre véritablement
de nos vies qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
avoir comme propositions sur l'écologie
le fait de se déplacer des circulations
véritablement qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient à disposition des gens je veux
dire le fait de mettre en fallon place
des vraies pistes cyclables oui la seule
piste cyclable qui lie à plaisir celle
qui amène du de la base de loisirs eux
qui passent par les gatinois
effectivement wee cc remettre les choses
au centre lui mais l'approché écologique
c'est un raisonnement global c'est quand
on construit quelque chose c'est en
tenir compte
c'est du début à la fin ça veut dire ccc
ccc dans le don dans la proche c'est
dans l'assiette de nos enfants c'est
dans la circulation plaisir web c'est
tout et il ya plusieurs peuples et
menton qui leur donne des raisons nous
comme on dit aujourd'hui que faire que
faire déjà réfléchir différemment
et encore une fois je reviens sur la
logique de base ce n'est pas l'argent
qui gouverne tout il ya de l'humain
autour de tout ça ça vient on pourra
continuer à faire en sorte que plaisir
s'étendent à tout va et que ce soit un
centre commercial encore plus grand
c'est quoi c'est de la pollution en
permanence c'est quoi comme emploi c'est
de l'emploi précaire vous voyez vous me
parler d'écologie l'écologie s'est donné
les moyens aux gens de vivre et par
exemple commercial on précise qu'un
nouveau centre commercial un va ouvrir
tout prochainement c'est open sky sur la
commune de plaisir on a parlé de la
démocratie locale de l'écologie le
troisième socle de votre réaction sur la
démarche c'est véritablement là quand on
parle et d'orientation ces éléments
titre l'émancipation des gens et
l'égalité en qualité l'émancipation des
gens c'est on part du principe que les
gens sont à même de pouvoir décider pour
eux-mêmes
vous parlez de démocratie locale c'est
donner aux gens la possibilité de
s'émanciper c'est quoi c'est leur ouvrir
véritablement la vie la vie publique la
vie publique la vie politique de notre
de notre cité et qui se leurrait qu'ils
se réapproprient leur vie leur ville et
quand vous nous aidez vous me donnez le
troisième choc lille là c'est vraiment
l'émancipation des gens ça rsa c'est ça
fait ça fait doux rêveur mais je suis
désolé l'utopie fait partie notre monde
aujourd'hui et sur le fond on se rend
bien compte avec tous les mouvements qui
ont eu lieu ces derniers temps les gens
ont envie que ça change
ils en ont marre qu'on décide pour eux
donc nous notre démarche est
véritablement aller à la rencontre des
gens comme on l'a fait depuis le début
de notre de notre mandature savez on
continue à avoir une approche et inna
qu'un accueil des gens qui est très très
très agréable pour eux parce que nous
n'avons pas fait de commentaires et de
promesses ou des choses complètement
erronée on avait mis en avant
des éléments sur notamment les emprunts
toxiques le fait que ça allait coûter un
freak mansart comme disait certain
aujourd'hui tout semble avait mis en
avant donc oui on est on est lucide et
pourquoi on élucide parce qu'on est
resté il n'est resté sur sur nos bases
et on est resté au contact des gens et
je pense que c'est ça nous l'approchons
ne parliez de nos démarches la démarche
et de conclure ce qu on arrivé là
allez on en retient c'est court mais sur
le principe notre démarche à descendre
c'est de changer les choses est de
changer les choses on peut pas changer
les choses avec les personnes qui vous
ont créé les problèmes qui sont ceux de
notre ville aujourd'hui donc le
changement c'est ça on retrouve je
précise l'ensemble des agents d'adp
campagne des candidats sur notre site
internet et v60 18 points comme merci
djamel agnès maupassant en plateau
candidats à plaisir sur la liste à
gauche tout à tête de liste d' à gauche
toutes sont également en course
officiellement la maire sortante josy
phil godman ce berger pour un troisième
mandat patrick j'enterre ancien adjoint
de la ville et annie joël prix ou admis
avec la liste taf
je précise d'ailleurs avant de refermer
ce journal un cas l'occasion de la
campagne des élections municipales tv 78
et radio sensations propose des débats
entre les candidats devils yvelinois ce
soir émission consacrée à la commune
d'elancourt débat retrouver à 20h sur tv
78 également sur la fréquence 98.4 pour
nos confrères de radio sensations
yvelines voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci d'avoir suivi belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]